c'est une élection serrée on veut
pouvoir former un gouvernement fort on
n'est pas obligé d'alterner entre les
deux vieux partis sur la plupart des
grands enjeux
ces gens j'ai l'habitude de nous
provoquer des surprises et canadiens
veulent du vrai changement
est ce que je leur demande pour un
gouvernement majoritaire
oui quand les livres alors on a besoin
moi j'ai toujours confiance à son
adversaire dans cette campagne
électorale s'estime un peu plus que
quatre jours nous allons revenir sur
cette campagne qui a été longue qui nous
a réservé bien des surprises et qu'ils
réservent peut-être encore d'autres
selon un dernier sondage la maison
écosse libéraux et conservateurs sont au
coude à coude avec 33 5% libéraux 32,6
son conservateur avait dit en troisième
place 10 points derrière 23% alors
daniel est à ottawa bon sens daniel
bonsoir et avec moi ici d'achat alors
justin trudeau dont il y avait le vent
dans les voiles c'est devenu un peu plus
ses rites cette affaire de dan gagnier
sa démission est ce que ça peut lui
faire mal michel bassez la première
reçue en fait qui s'abat sur la tête des
libéraux depuis le début de la campagne
mais la bonne nouvelle c'est que ça
arrive très tard et je pense ça va être
relativement relativement facile à gérer
je pense pas que ça provoque une
désaffection hamas de vote libéral mais
dans des comptes est très serré je pense
au québec en particulier
ça réveille des mauvais souvenirs on a
vu aujourd'hui
tam se rappelle que ce week-end ont
ressuscité le spectre des commandites et
il ya beaucoup de gens aussi qui se
disent monsieur trudeau où on sait pas
trop qui derrière lui de qui c'est qui a
eu toutes ces bonnes idées là durant la
campagne et on faisait beaucoup de gens
pressés des magouilleurs c'est un peu
inquiétant mais au total je pense le
dommage doit être limité sacha penser
que ça peut faire mal à justin trudeau
ça ferait un peu bas et je pense que
l'on voit déjà monsieur mulcair qui sont
là dessus et dire que c'est
c'est l'ancienne façon de faire et ses
graines rien de changement c'est pas
nouveau mais je sais pas si ça va coller
autant en fait parce qu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup de temps qui reste
mais aussi parce que monsieur cani n'est
pas un personnage qui est à l'extérieur
du québec en tout cas très bien connu le
canada anglais messieurs gagner c'est
pas quelqu'un je pense que les gens vont
dire au monde y pense pas comme un mike
duffy par exemple alors je pense qu'il
va avoir des dégâts mais ce serait un
peu inconnu à daniel lui coûter à dan
gagnier n'a rien fait d'illégal sauf
qu'il a fait preuve de sérieux manque de
jugement
dans le cas de justin trudeau will a
reconnu l'erreur sauf que est-ce qu'il
n'aurait pas dû souvent dès le départ
que dans le gagner faisait ce genre
d'affaires presque du lobby ce même s'il
n'est pas reconnu comme tel à ottawa là
aussi une question de jugement qui se
posent sauf que je suis un peu d'accord
avec michel et achats les conséquences
ne seront peut-être pas très bien on y
peut y en avoir
les questions d'éthique hassan et
fluence pas toujours les gens à moins
que ce soit énorme comme dans la cause
du scandale des commandites
bon alors passons à ce bilan on est
soixante quinze jours plus tard quand
même on a décidé d'y aller de façon un
peu plus ludique par catégorie on va
commencer par la catégorie du pire
moment de cette campagne électorale on
commence avec vous tout achat ok moi le
pire moment
c'était effectivement qu'en mai sera
prêt à pousser la question du niqab trop
loin j'étais en accord avec lui que sur
la question des cérémonies de
citoyenneté
environ 80 pour cent des canadiens
disent eh oui visage découvert s'il vous
plaît 93% même hockey au québec c'est
même plus haut et on a la loi aussi
proposer six sur la question de la
fonction publique
mais le reste du canada n'avait pas eu
cette discussion de la fonction publique
alors quand messieurs harper est allé la
semaine après il a dit peut-être je vais
pousser ça plus loin dans une entrevue
avec la bbc il a dit ça ça fait surtout
les gens parce que ce n'était pas
quelque chose qui était sur la table et
pour moi c'était là on en voyait
justement les libéraux prendre encore
plus de vent dans leurs voiles et je
pense c'était une réaction que c'est
et là ça allait trop loin pour la
majorité les électeurs à les couvrir
beaucoup de places en tout cas dans
cette campagne michel valet le pire
moment à mon sens c'est quand on a vu le
petit rien le mort sur une plage c'est à
des images très très lourd dit la
réaction de monsieur harper a été
vraiment atroce ce soir là je pense que
monsieur apple il ya quelque chose qui
s'est cassé dans l'opinion des gens sont
dits non là il ya toujours un boulot
c'est pas le genre de canada qu'on veut
monsieur a mal réagi et l'ensemble de la
scène et a été très très pénibles pour
je pense pour beaucoup de canadiens
daniel le pire moment
moi je sais le supplice de la goutte est
posée assis leur a peut d'abord sur
michael d'offer ensuite sur la récession
qui n'était pas vraiment une mais ça a
été difficile
et puis comme michel de signal sur les
migrants a à plusieurs reprises on a vu
monsieur harper le visage crispé est
tentant de sourire au milieu de ses
partisans exaspéré qui hurlaient des
insultes aux journalistes rappelez vous
ce citoyen de cette électeurs
conservateurs de toronto elle savait
peut être un moment mémorable sauf que
quand vous êtes premier ministre vous
devez vous attendre à avoir des
questions aux difficiles des moments
difficiles et c'est râpé avait personne
d'autre que lui à blâmer c'est lui qui a
nommé sévin grimpeur c'est lui qui a
misé beaucoup trop sur le pétrole ce qui
affecte l'économie a retrouvé la
récession et sur les migrants à michel
delattre a bien expliqué que son
compassion qui n'était pas là oui
réaction face aux journalistes
aujourd'hui justin trudeau a montré
qu'ils pouvaient avoir un peu de fougue
en tout cas il arrive ya réagi assez
vertement il c'était une bonne
récupération aussi de toute l'histoire
de dingue
bon le meilleur coût de cette campagne
la meilleure idée est la meilleure
stratégie on commence avec vos michel je
passais la décision monsieur trudeau ou
en tout cas de ceux qui l'ont conseillé
de rompre avec le dogme du déficit zéro
c'est un audacieux téméraire même ça
aurait pu mal tourner l'action des
analyses mais finalement ça a bien
tourné et ça vraiment marquer le coup du
changement la partir de ce moment là
monsieur trudeau a réussi à incarner le
vraiment l'alternative à stephen harper
pour moi c'est indéniablement le
tournant de la campagne daniel c'est
pourquoi aussi le tournant de la
campagne mais quand moi je pense que tu
as chaud voire de même tourner alors
pour me démarquer
je dirais je vous dirai peut-être les
débats télévisés on était tellement
convaincu que justin trudeau je perde de
son je peux vous m'entendez encore que
justin trudeau allait se casser la
gueule
rappelez-vous que clarika les quarts et
enak de monsieur qui a dit le seul fait
que justin trudeau seront nos premiers
débats en portant ses pantalons ce sera
déjà au delà des attentes et je vous
dirais que 5,5 c'est cette semaine plus
tard ces corps étaient là qui est des
culottes et oui je n'imaginais pas je
vais pas y aller la mairie je suis en
accord avec mes deux confrères et s'il a
été pointée non vraiment un tournant
parce que ça marquer un point où l'un
des des libéraux ont changé de place
dans un sens sur le spectrum politique
et qu'on voyait vraiment que monsieur
trudeau allait récupérer tous les
électeurs qui se demandaient peut-être
parce que l'un des deux avait trop aller
au centre parce que l'intériste vraiment
le changement qu'ils cherchaient
particulièrement au québec où les gens
ont une expérience présent avec
l'austérité
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ne l'aiment
pas alors ça pour moi c'était c'était le
moment le meilleur coup mais c'est vrai
au moment que ça s'est passé j'ai pensé
c'était un train un très grand risque
est peut-être négatif mais tout le monde
d'ailleurs trouvé vraiment ça allait
contre lisant une certaine idée qu'ont
qu'on s'est fait peut-être et ce qui est
intéressant d'aller en 6 et que les
libérons attendus ils ont attendu avec
leurs plateformes tout le monde les
critiquer est-ce que ça va être dévoilée
ils ont attendu que le npd montrent leur
plate forme et avec un déficit zéro et
là ils pouvaient faire l'inversé
bon alors la déception de cette campagne
pour vous daniel que si vous êtes déçu
écoutez pour pour la première fois je
pense dans l'histoire du canada les
canadiens étaient prêts à voter pour un
parti de gauche modérément de gauche le
nouveau parti démocratique
pour eux le npd a toujours été la
conscience et canadiens de fuite en
vidant gueuse rêver de l'ouest puis elle
brade banny se disait peut-être que le
npd est prêt à gouverner pour une
première fois au canada a je pense que
thomas mulcair a déçu beaucoup
néo-démocrate en ramenant ce parti la
hausse en en faisant une fixation avec
un déficit zéro l'austérité et cetera ce
qui est contraire aux grands principes
des néo démocrates et à partir de ce
moment là le npd est devenu un parti
comme les autres un vieux parti qui a
les mêmes préoccupations que les
conservateurs ou les libéraux et à
partir de ce moment là écoutez ça peut
encore arriver mais mais les chances que
que le npd forme le prochain
gouvernement sur le plus en plus mince
tâche à moi ma grande déception c'est
que les gens ne veulent pas des héros
sorti la carte de crédit c'est licorne
et arc en ciel on peut tout acheter
je trouve ça complètement irresponsable
parce que je ne pense pas dans le
contexte économique on a besoin de le
faire
ce n'est pas 2008 2009 du tout alors
pour moi ces observations la queue on
cherche
cette solution pourrait être différent
samedi soir d'abord nous dit qu'il faut
créer l'emploi à vie il faudrait la
vision oui oui ben moi j'ai exactement
les positions inverses rencontre des
gens trouvent que l'état encore un rôle
à jouer et qu'il le joue à plein
maintenant ma déception c'est exactement
la même que celle de daniel monsieur
manquer
a joué beaucoup trop conservateur dans
tous les sens du terme dans cette
campagne on sait la pire des trois
campagnes on dégringole pas de temps
pointe du début à la fin même si elle
était longue sans qu on ait commis des
fautes en état us mais je trouve que
très mal géré aussi la sphère du niqab
il ya malien mal positionné son il y
aurait pu très bien pu passer à la fois
pour un champion des doigts tout en
disant écoutez comme au québec le visage
découvert c'est un principe qui
normalement dans la note est dans la
nature humaine alors du temps il a mis
beaucoup trop de chats il le mal était
déjà fait alors qu'est ce qu'on va
retenir de cette longue campagne quand
même on le disait c'était la première
fois que c'est aussi long pour vous
tasha c'est qu'elle était trop longue
effectivement et je pense le
gouvernement conservateur a fait un pari
que dans la longue campagne il avait
beaucoup d'argent et ne pouvait plus
dépensiers que ce serait à leur avantage
et ce qu'on voit c'est que ça permet ce
qu'on appelle en anglais le comeback kid
ça permet à quelqu'un de faire une
montée on a vu que l'inde est descendu
parce qu'ils ont commencé en première
position c'est normal mais que ces
libéraux qui ont monté après ça ils
n'ont pas les conservateurs pour prendre
la place alors la leçon peut-être ici
qu'on revienne aux campagnes du coup oui
bonne idée si des chiens moi ce qui m'a
frappé c'est le j'ai jamais vu une
campagne aussi manichéenne et les
personnages il était parfait pour 7,7 de
campagne là d'un côté vous avez
machiavel en personne apple utilise tous
les trucs les plus tordus et de l'autre
côté il ya monsieur trudeau qui arrive
avec une candeur un peu une générosité
un peu naïve et et kiki vraiment de
faire un compte d alice qui fait un
contre est extraordinaire avec avec
monsieur et dans un
menkes comme celui-là le groupe qui est
d'un milieu a inévitablement l'air un
peu pâle un peu de rab ce qui est arrivé
à monsieur mulcair
j'avais jamais vu mois une campagne où
tu avais les bons et les méchants d'une
façon aussi contrastantes et on arrive à
daniel vous qu'est ce que vous retenez
finalement que ça a été que ça a été
beaucoup trop lourd aussi qu'on a
escamoté des questions aux principales
selon la boussole de radio canada et
c'est une excellente mesure on peut
parler à peu près pas de santé ni
d'environnement qui sont les deux
grandes priorités
encore moins de culture qui a l'air de
n'intéresser absolument personne dans
ces partis politiques à deuxièmement
pour une fois on a parlé beaucoup
d'affaires international n'est pas parce
qu'on voulait le faire parce qu'on était
à la remorque des événements forcé de le
faire comme dans le cas des migrants et
troisièmement depuis le début les
canadiens se disent il faut du
changement il faut du changement
mais ils sont encore nombreux à se
demander est ce que est ce que
l'alternative au changement
l'alternative à stephen harper 16 m²
trudeau c'est vraiment du changement est
ce que ça vaut vraiment la peine qu'on
ait le bon il nous reste deux catégories
je veux vraiment les frères mais c'est
alors lundi soir trois petits points
qu'est ce que vous allez sur les michel
moi je surveille le vote francophone de
monsieur trudeau est ce que monsieur
trudeau ferait vraiment une percée au
québec dans l'électorat francophone et
parce que la question qu'on se pose à ce
que les québécois sont maintenant prêts
à jouer le jeu politique canadien ce
qu'ils ont refusé de faire depuis
pratiquement le rapatriement j'accepte
un épisode de monsieur mulroney mais
autrement ce monsieur chrétien ou si la
montée ne va pas pouvoir profiter plutôt
aux blacks les gens vont des baleines
pde a plus besoin de nous pour battre
les conservateurs alors on est toujours
bien pas pour voter pour monsieur pour
monsieur trudeau ou alors
j'ai hâte de voir quelle performance se
trouve à faire chez elle vous avez
surveiller beaucoup de choses puisque
vous serez évidemment la soirée
électorale
je vais surveiller surtout le québec je
pense c'est là où ça va être le plus
intéressant combien de députés le bloc
québécois aux faire élire cinq dix
quinze plus - est-ce que les
conservateurs vont doubler leur nombre
de députés en ont cinq ans ce moment
pour eux ce serait une grande victoire
est ce que est ce que les libéraux la la
montée constante depuis quelques jours
voir jusqu'au québec qui se manifestait
un nombre de sièges
et combien de sièges le nouveau parti
démocratique membre parce que je pense
que c'était inévitable
québec ça va être très intéressant à
part le québec moi je vais surveiller la
grande base et vous aussi à la soirée
électorale oui mais à toronto et les
communautés ethniques la différence en
deux voies que la dernière fois en 2000
ans était là comme une technique qu'il a
fait en grande partie pour les
conservateurs est ce qu'ils vont garder
ses chatons format et en
colombie-britannique aussi c'est une
lutte à trois présentement qu'est ce qui
va arriver là bas personne le sait
dernière chose je peux pas vous laisser
partir sans vous demander vos
prédictions michel rapidement libéral
minoritaire va pas être un gouvernement
npd
voilà libéral ou conservateur
minoritaire minoritaire mais aussi
daniel moi je me répète mais je le
répète encore le voit conservateur est
toujours sous-estimé à seewen un peu à
une organisation très solide beaucoup
d'argent mais chaque fois que je fais
des prévisions politique mais non daniel
pourquoi alors merci beaucoup à vous
trois nous on va se retrouver mardi soir
donc pour analyser les résultats de
cette de cette élection
vous vous faut aussi dimanche soir à
tous merci beaucoup à vous trois alors
bonne bon vote tout le monde